you mentioned Hillary Clinton's tweet
has this changed your view or your
investment profile in the pharmaceutical
space no you know I think it's actually
a very interesting area
I think Bloomberg put out a piece on
kind of drug pricing there was a cover
story the Journal today talked about I
think the top 30 drugs
the average price increase over the last
several years or something like 60%
average you know so drug pricing is
certainly something that has the
potassium well I assume for Hillary
Clinton so therefore this is something
that becomes a campaign issue but I
think if you if you think about it you
know take a very big picture approach we
have the most innovative biopharma sort
of industry in the world and the reason
for that is that you can make a lot of
money and drug business and those
profits get redeployed into Rd they get
redeployed into buying successful
biotechnology companies the investors
make money and they put more capital in
and you get a self-fulfilling prophecy
of more and more innovation and you know
that's a cycle that you know I think we
want to continue you know obviously if
you know you're a consumer and you're
all of a sudden you're drug goes up
massively in price you know that's
something you're any sensitive to but I
think there's you know there's a lot of
misinformation you know you know sort of
the gross prices that are talked about
in terms of where pharmaceutical
companies mark drugs or sell drugs are
very few people if any a gross price you
know the fall kind but it's Medicare
Medicaid you know PBMs whatever your
your health plan is you know these are
negotiated transactions
well ethics seems to be one of the
central issues and clearly ethics is
important to you when you look at
Herbalife one of the reasons you've been
I'm gonna say on this crusade against
Herbalife is because you think it is
such an unethical company but in terms
of what we see we've seen a drug pricing
I mean a hedge fund manager buying a
company that sells a drug to patients
who have HIV that is priced at $7 and he
jacks it up to $700 in your opinion it's
legal he is exercising his right in the
free markets it's a loophole it's an
ethical is it the right thing to do
that's not my favorite version of how to
make money for sure and obviously those
kind of glaring examples are are going
to attract a lot of attention you know
there's been a lot of attention on
valiant valiant cuts you know drag
into the story in a very small part of
aliens business is sort of repricing
drugs but even you know let's just sort
of talk me one of the things Hillary
Clinton spoke about in her health plan
was a requirement that pharma companies
spend a certain percentage of their
revenues on R&D sort of this you know
for spending on it which is not what
valiant does it's not what valiant does
and and valiant was criticized by
Gretchen Morgenson an article in The
Times mentioning all the competitive
media make sure I don't get invited
you know her point was well valiance not
spending as only spending three percent
of revenues in R&D isn't as bad for
America and the answer is no actually I
think what's interesting about valiant
is we think valiant has made a massive
contribution to drug development you
know more so than almost any other
company how so here's how you think
about it so we've got to follow the
money all right so what does valiant
doesn't pay a dividend so there's no
cash leaving the system they're not
buying back stock right so they generate
a lot of cash flow where does it go well
they spend about three percent of
revenues and R&D they spend money
building plans to make pharmaceuticals
they pay their employees stick with me
for a second compare that three percent
on R&D to other companies in their space
okay this is my point so that so valiant
believes that they are not good at drug
development ie are really coming up with
new molecules and taking them all the
way to the approval process that's a has
been historically a very low return
business that their view is that the
startup biotechnology companies can much
easier recruit you know the top
scientists you know today if you're a
top scientist in the space and you want
to you know make some money you can go
work for Pfizer and you can make a few
hundred thousand dollar bonus have you
come up with a drug or alternatively you
can get backed by a venture capitalist
and you could form a company you can
discover a drug and you can make a
billion dollars
it's